sur une inquiétude qui alourdit encore
un peu plus l'atmosphère notamment à new
york cette semaine après le double
attentat la population a beaucoup de mal
à évacuer le traumatisme les new yorkais
apprennent aussi à vivre avec la peur
reportage stéphanie perez et marc felix
cette image est celle qui ont suivi
n'ont pas fini de hanter les new yorkais
ils sont des centaines à avoir
immortaliser ces instants tragiques le
11 septembre aujourd'hui dans cette
galerie du quartier branché de soho
photographe d'un jour ou amateurs
passionnés ils viennent d'afficher ses
photos pour partager ce qu'ils ont vécu
pour en parler en guise de thérapie
j'ai passé l'été à les photographier ces
12 et puis elles ont explosé
c'est comme si j'avais été touché
personnellement jong
il y a un besoin incroyable de
communautés chez un endroit où les gens
puissent partager leur peine et aussi
leur sentiment sur ce qui est arrivé cet
endroit est fait pour ça
soudain conscient de leur vulnérabilité
les new-yorkais ne trouvent pas de
réponses à leurs questions depuis l'
attaquent les églises ne désemplissent
pas
chaque dimanche depuis les faits le
pasteur ici évoque le drame et termine
la messe par l'hymne national repris en
choeur
c'est très émouvant mais les gens besoin
d'exprimer leurs émotions et nous sommes
là pour les aider
à défaut de comprendre new york se
tourner vers ce qu'elle a érigé en héros
ces pompiers disparus pour continuer à
avancer les new-yorkais se nourrissent
du courage et du sens du sacrifice de
leurs sauveteurs
les casernes aujourd'hui encore
reçoivent des milliers de messages de
soutien
je suis venu pour essayer de donner un
sens à ce qui est arrivé et puis aussi
pour leur prouver ma gratitude
un hommage énorme à la hauteur du besoin
qu'ont les américains de croire encore
en certaines de leurs valeurs que cette
journée du 11 septembre a complètement
remise en cause
et puis une nouvelle